[Música]
es una maratónica jornada para el senado
estadounidense
los republicanos llevan a cabo un
ajustado cronograma que han diseñado
para confirmar
amy cón y barrett como el reemplazo de
la fallecida jueza ruth báder ginsburg
este lunes la propia barrett y los
senadores ofrecerán sus declaraciones de
apertura y se espera que este martes la
nominada del presidente de donald trump
sea sometida a un interrogatorio por
parte del comité judicial una vez
aprobada en dicho comité habrá una
votación final para que barrett sea
confirmada oficialmente este escenario
es muy probable ya que el partido del
presidente cuenta con la mayoría en el
senado las nominaciones para la corte
suprema- toman un promedio de 70 días
pero los republicanos esperan que todo
el procedimiento suceda antes de las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre es decir
en tres semanas previendo una eventual
derrota que les arrebataría el control
de la casa blanca de anexos primeros
demócratas reciente en que en 2016 el
senado se negara a considerar al
candidato de barack obama para llegar a
la corte suprema alegando que había un
año electoral de por medio con la
llegada de bar
al máximo tribunal los conservadores
incrementarían su mayoría con seis
jueces frente a tres liberales los
demócratas temen que con este escenario
peligren el derecho al aborto y las
protecciones en el sistema de salud